[Musica]
allora la mia sfida è stata far
succedere dynamo camp
e la cosa è stata anche emozionante
complicata
devo dire devo salire risalire a qualche
anno fa
qualche anno fa quando un imprenditore
mi ha chiesto lascia la tua azienda dove
tu hai lavorato tanti anni che tu ami
per seguire la mia sfida che è quella
che invece di fare il filantropo in
questo paese in italia e dimostrare che
si possono fare grandi imprese sociali
usando le stesse competenze che si usano
nel mondo dell'impresa per il 2004 era
decisamente una sfida un po da matti
perché volevamo costruire il primo camp
in italia dedicato a patologie gravi e
croniche ospitare gratuitamente ragazzi
bambini e ragazzi che sono stati tanto
tempo in ospedale che sono affetti da
malattie molto gravi come il tumore come
malattie croniche del sangue come per
esempio il diabete è una malattia
cronica però dove i ragazzi devono
imparare a gestire la loro patologia
alle loro medicine come le disabilità o
le sindromi rare regalare loro una
vacanza completamente gratuita in un
luogo che doveva essere ed è molto bello
e anche molto sicuro la fortuna ci ha
aiutato
abbiamo incontrato questo progetto negli
stati uniti che si chiama appunto
serious man children's network che era
stato creato e voluto pensate
dall'attore paul newman il mio
presidente enzo ho deciso di portarlo in
italia da imprenditore così abbiamo
iniziato a costruire un progetto dove
l'idea era quella di donare a questi
ragazzi che non sono stati bambini
perché la loro malattia dato il tanto
tempo in ospedale e alle famiglie che
improvvisamente magari nascono anno
questo ragazzo questo bambino sano ed è
improvviso
l'evento smette di parlare o smette di
camminare o smette di mangiare regalare
loro una cosa molto semplice quella di
ritornare a essere bambini quella di
ritornare a essere genitori insieme ad
altri genitori che hanno tutti la stessa
difficoltà quindi i nostri camper sono
quelli che noi chiamiamo camper sono
ragazzi che i bambini che hanno vissuto
tanto tempo in ospedale e la malattia e
le patologie le hanno resi diciamo
bambini speciali quindi dinamo crema è
stato disegnato sul modello americano
con l'idea che ogni attività possa
essere completamente accessibile
possibile e divertente per qualsiasi
tipo di difficoltà fisica per qualsiasi
ragazzo per qualsiasi disabilità allora
la sfida come potete immaginare se da
quella di implementare un luogo dove
tutto doveva essere bellissimo molto
sicuro con la presenza di medici e
infermieri continue residenti dove i
genitori addirittura scelgono di portare
i loro bambini dai 6 ai 12 anni o dei 13
e 17 e andare via
lasciano i loro figli malati oppure
ancora in terapia oppure disabili a
dynamo camp e vanno via e quindi noi
abbiamo l'importante responsabilità di
farle divertire in sicurezza il modello
con il quale noi lavoriamo che è un po
la sfida che poi ognuno di noi deve
compiere per ogni settimana di vacanza
di questi ragazzi per i diciotto
programmi all'anno che svolgiamo tutto
l'anno e quindi a ospitare duemila
persone più o meno a dynamo camp in modo
completamente gratuito e far sì che ogni
attività di quelle che svolgono i
ragazzi sia completamente sicura e molto
divertente
malgrado tu magari abbia una difficoltà
fisica o sesso una sedia rotelle o
magari hai paura di confrontarti con i
tuoi coetanei perché i tuoi coetanei ti
spaventano perché la tua malattia ha
creato in te un vuoto un limite o ti
senti diverso
e così abbiamo applicato e ogni volta
applichiamo e ogni volta ogni anno
decidiamo come diventare più bravi
e quella che noi chiamiamo terapia
ricreativa che è una specie di cerchio
all'interno del quale ogni ragazzo
compie una sfida è questa sfida la deve
scegliere una volta che la scelta decide
di fare questa attività decide di salire
su una arrampicata che al 38 metri anche
sulla sedia a rotelle
la sfida la sceglie perché ci sono delle
persone che lo aiutano e che sono
appunto il nostro staff ei nostri
volontari ad affrontarla e poi si
riflette si riflette su quello che è
successo gli insegniamo a raccontarsi ea
capire come sono riusciti ad affrontarla
e per alcuni può essere anche stare su
un palco davanti a un microfono della
radio lavorare no in un'opera artistica
fare un musical l'arrampicata al tiro
con l'arco e tutte queste cose
meravigliose l'impatto di questo
successo che viene appunto sul quale si
riflette e che poi nella sfida
successiva
tu hai una forza in più per poterla
affrontare e quindi la riflessione dopo
il raggiungimento del successo è una
fase fondamentale noi abbiamo misurato
che i nostri ragazzi aumentano quella
che noi chiamiamo autostima l'autostima
è il modo con il quale tu affronti la
vita quindi passi nove giorni al dynamo
camp
ma poi esci e hai la possibilità di
affrontare altri fatti della vita di
fare amicizia con altre persone di poter
affrontare anche e magari i tuoi
insegnanti oi tuoi ambienti sociali o
magari un nuovo sport senza avere paura
di svolgere no di andare oltre i tuoi
confini alto i tuoi limiti e quindi per
esempio quest'anno vi danno kemp ha
implementato la prima parete
d'arrampicata quindi abbiamo un circolo
un ciclo arrampicata nel quale i ragazzi
anche con la sedia rotelle possono
salire su questo percorso arrivare circa
8 metri e poi fare quella che viene
chiamata zip line con la stessa sedia
rotelle questo è l'unico luogo in europa
che permette ai ragazzi di fare questo
percorso con la loro sedia a rotelle che
vuol dire che tutti possano ad arrivare
e fare la stessa attività
immaginate
e quindi in un gruppo di 95 la
meraviglia di avere ciascuno affrontato
la stessa attività malgrado la loro
diversità e questo è un po diciamo il
motivo per cui dynamo camp è così
speciale in questi anni abbiamo visto e
siamo fortunati abbiamo visto crescere
il nostro progetto perché ciascuno di
noi si è impegnato noi siamo un gruppo
di persone che ha iniziato molto piccolo
eravamo in tre o quattro e oggi
aggreghiamo facciamo lavorare più di 56
persone
76 ragazzi stagionali e 850 volontari
quindi in realtà siamo tante persone che
fanno succedere dynamo camp è quello che
succede a dynamo camp è in effetti
magico ma può essere riprodotto anche
fuori da dynamo camp
quello che stiamo vedendo succedere che
i ragazzi che hanno superato i 17 anni
tornano oggi e fanno i volontari di
dinamo alcuni di loro lavorano presso di
noi altri di loro sono in giro a
sviluppare progetti simili perché hanno
capito che nulla è impossibile
la vera la vera sfida che noi ci poniamo
tutte le volte è anche di capire come
con il personale medico e
infermieristico si possano affrontare
alcune difficoltà e quindi durante una
settimana di camp per esempio insegniamo
loro a gestire le loro malattie a
gestire le loro medicine a gestire anche
il tempo della loro medicina quindi non
è il bambino e la medicina non è la
medicina al centro ma il bambino al
centro quindi se stai facendo
l'arrampicata se in piscina siamo noi
attraverso appunto il personale medico
infermieristico che lo portiamo ma
portiamo la medicina nelle varie aree di
attività e questo è un comportamento che
poi aiuta anche il personale medico
infermieristico quando esce a dynamo
camp a pensare in terapia ricreativa
anche quando è in ospedale
quindi il centro ovviamente importante
seguire le proprie protocolli medici ma
poi la cosa più importante è capire il
benessere complessivo della famiglia e
così vale anche per il nucleo familiare
quando papà mamma fratello sarà un
fratello malato arrivano dynamo camp
sono disorientati molte di queste
famiglie con bambini disabili non hanno
altri luoghi dove andare in vacanza o
non sono mai andate in vacanza o non
sono mai uscite di casa perché si
vergognano perché loro figlio figlia
magari fa rumore o fa dei gesti strani
allora in quel contesto come il nostro
trovano altri genitori dove possono
raccontare parlare di cose molto
pratiche dove possono fare logopedia
come si fa fisioterapia come affronti
una certa fase della crescita come si
affronta l'adolescenza con un bambino
con disabilità
no come ci si accetta come se aiuto ai
propri figli ad accettare il proprio
corpo come si pensa al futuro
immaginate ci sono genitori che hanno
delle diagnosi di morte definite allora
come si affronta il futuro ci sono
famiglie che sono più avanti famiglie
che sono più indietro quindi di fatto
noi non curiamo nessuno dirà ma offre
un'opportunità che in questa opportunità
le persone si incontrano e fanno
succedere le cose quindi la cosa che
vediamo dopo 12 anni di vita non
soltanto questo gruppo di ragazzi che
ritorna e vuole lavorare da noi ma i
nostri volontari che sono chiunque ciao
ragazzi che hanno dai 18 anni in su fino
non c'è limite superiore decidono di
venire dynamo camp con l'obiettivo di
mettersi all'ascolto mettersi al
servizio dimenticarsi di se stessi
mettersi mettere al centro i ragazzi e
questo fa succedere delle cose
incredibili incredibili perché i bambini
in questo modo si liberano di tutte
quelle paure che il mondo li pone che
l'ospedale gli porta che magari i
compagni di classe volte no li prendono
in giro a dynamo camp sipri a questo
contesto senza giudizio e poi quando tu
ti abitui da volontario a non esprimere
un giudizio a non esercitare il tuo
giudizio a pensare all inclusive ita
sempre a far sì che non esiste un
attività non possibile esiste la tua
capacità di adattare con l'attivita a
quella persona questo modo di pensare
quando è uscita dynamo camp diventa il
modo di comportarsi poi dei nostri
volontari quindi noi stiamo creando in
realtà penso spero una comunità
persone che la vedrà in modo diverso sui
temi dell'inclusione della diversità
pur non mettendo se stessi al centro ma
mettendo quindi l'altro al centro e
questo è un esercizio magari primo anno
ti riesce bene secondo anno che ti
forniti riesce ancora meglio il terzo
anno decidi che per te è troppo e quindi
preferisce non fare più il volontario
dinamo stessa cosa vale per i nostri
ragazzi per lo staff per i fornitori per
i donatori per tutto il mondo che si sta
creando intorno a noi e quindi ci sono
altri progetti che questo dynamo camp ha
fatto crescere e sta facendo nascere in
vari territori italiani che vogliono
proprio portare questo concetto di
terapia ricreativa all'interno delle
loro realtà e quindi come posso dire che
di fatto la vera sfida è stata non
soltanto far succedere diremo kemp in un
gruppo di persone che ci ha creduto ma
anche e soprattutto lottare per i tuoi
diritti fondamentali il diritto alla
felicità dei ragazzi di tutti noi di
tutti i bambini qualsiasi difficoltà e
si abbiano il diritto alla normalità dei
genitori delle famiglie che questo è il
desiderio più grande che hanno e per
questo per noi continueremo a lottare a
cercare di fare di più e migliorare e
allargare il nostro progetto e farlo
conoscere tante persone
grazie